I did not expect my senior year for any
of this to be happening especially in
Davis after multiple killings near the
University of California Davis there's
still no suspect in custody three
stabbings over the last week all within
roughly a mile of campus in a small city
which hadn't seen a homicide since 2019.
it All Began last Thursday when the body
of 50 year old David bro was found with
multiple stab wounds in a local park
two days later UC Davis student Kareem
Abu najim was also stabbed to death in
another Park about a mile north of
Campus I just called on every every
person in a capacity to help to capture
whoever did this to please do so his
father says he was a free spirit his
spirit is is
way of doing things
will will be with us until our last day